OK, this is the thing.
We've done a lot of
work on ionic bonds.
And I drew the ionic bond
energy again, on Monday.
And remember, in
an ironic bond--
so let's take sodium chloride--
we have, oh, we're going
to go Lewis, right?
And people say, well, why
did I draw that dot there.
I could have drawn two dots
there and that dot there.
Sure.
Yeah.
But they're kind of
looking at each other.
So, you know.
[LAUGHTER]
And remember in an iconic bond
chlorine is like, give me!
I want!
And that's the kind of
relationship they have, right?
And so this went into
something like this, where
sodium was like, OK, fine.
Take it.
I'm a plus now.
And chlorine was like,
thank you very much.
I'm fully octeted, right?
Like that.
And that's the ionic bond.
So this is ionic.
And we learned this.
OK, but see, there is another
kind of bond that can happen.
It's not all about
taking and one per-- no.
It can also be about sharing.
About sharing.
So if I have hydrogen
instead, let's
suppose I have
hydrogen like up there.
And I've got hydrogen now.
And here is hydrogen.
Well, see when
they see-- geshundheit-- each
other, a very different thing
happens.
Because one of the hydrogens
doesn't say, gimme.
And the other one
doesn't say, sure.
Well, but something
else happens.
Because they get closer.
They get closer, and closer.
Oh!
Let's look at this in terms
of like, OK, so here's
a plus and minus.
Oh, yeah.
It's not an orbit,
it's an orbital!
And here's another plus,
and here's another minus.
And these electrons--
you know, the thing is,
the electrons are like, I
don't like you other electron.
You're repelling me.
And the protons are like, I
don't like you other proton.
You're repelling me.
But the electrons
do like protons.
And at a certain point, if
you bring these together,
one of them is like,
hey, I got an idea!
What if I'm attracted to
you sometimes, over here,
and I'm this electron.
I'm like, I want to
be attracted to you.
And I'll tell you what, you
can be attracted to my proton,
and we'll share.
We'll share.
And so, when these
come together,
what you get is the protons
are a certain distance apart,
that's set by how far you
can push them in without them
feeling that repulsion.
And the electrons-- as long
as they don't get like,
you know super on
top of each other,
because they're going
to repel each other--
they're happier.
They're happier because they
got two positive charges
that they can kind of
go around and be near.
That leads to happiness--
lower energy bond!
But you can see right now,
this is a very different kind
of bond.
Right?
This is not ionic.
This is covalent.
When share electrons
it's a covalent bond.
OK?
And that is something
we write differently.
We write it with a dash.
Well, or you could've
also written it--
or maybe you should say, well,
let's just put those electrons
in between them like that.
Right?
And it's showing that
those electrons didn't
go to one or the other,
they're in between.
They are what are making
up the bond together,
sharing those protons
across the atoms.
OK.
So that's nice.
That's hydrogen.
What happens when
we get to something a little
bit more complicated, right?
So let's go to water.
Now, if I have
something like water--
so now, I'm going to go
through some examples.
Let's suppose I have water.
Well, I've got this here,
and I've got this here.
And now, remember,
we're going to think
about things in
terms of Lewis dots,
which I introduced
to you on Monday.
Those are the valence electrons
in an atom, which are what
do all of the chemical bonding.
So those are the ones
we're going to carry.
Now, how many dots do I
have for oxygen. I forget.
Six!
Six.
And if you didn't know,
you know where to look.
Because you're always carrying
your periodic table with you--
always!
And so I might
write six like that.
OK.
What lines do I draw where?
How are these shared?
So how are the electrons
shared in covalent bonds?
Covalent bonds.
And that is where
Lewis will help.
That is where Lewis will help.
How do I take these valence
configurations of electrons
and make a molecule with these
kinds of sharing bonds in it?
And there's actually
a fairly simple recipe
that I want to teach you
today, because that's
how we're going to do it.
And the recipe is written here.
And don't worry, there's
a lot of text here,
but I'm going to go through it
for three different examples.
And if you haven't done Lewis--
I know some of you have in high
school, some of you have not.
That's OK.
If you haven't,
practice is really key.
All right?
We'll do three molecules,
maybe four, today.
And I encourage you to do
a bunch more as practice.
And this is the recipe for
drawing Lewis structures.
And Lewis structures is
what tells us how electrons
are bonded in these molecules.
And so, let's follow this
for the one I have up here.
Let's follow this for water.
OK?
So we're going to go
through this recipe.
Now, the first--
so, one through six.
I will write one through
six for the example.
I will parallel that recipe.
So first, connect atom central.
Central atom is often the
least electronegative-- already
I'm stuck!
Because I didn't
tell you anything
about electronegativity.
That's coming a little later.
Today, I will tell you
what electronegativity is.
For now, trust me.
So the first step
is connect atoms.
Central atom is often the
least electronegative.
OK.
Well, so let's see.
So for water, so step one, the H
atoms are going to be terminal.
That means that
they're on the outside.
Terminal.
OK?
Outside.
They're also called terminal.
And so, the arrangement should
be something like H, O, and H.
OK, good.
So that's going to
be my arrangement.
OK.
Step two-- determine the total
number of valence electrons.
OK, I can do that.
So two.
Well, I've got
one, two , three--
OK.
I've got eight
valence electrons.
Good.
OK.
Step three is where
it gets really fun.
Place bonding pair of electrons.
Go all in, just like I did for--
So there's a bonding
pair right there.
There they are.
Two electrons in a bonding pair.
So place bonding pair
between adjacent atoms.
OK.
I can do that.
So let's see.
Here we go.
H, O, H. Right?
OK.
So there's my bonding pair.
I put two electrons.
But now, you see, OK, I only
used up four electrons there.
OK?
Now, starting with that,
now add enough electrons
to each one to form an octet.
Start with terminal atoms,
add enough electrons
to form an octet.
OK?
So let's see.
But hydrogen is special, because
hydrogen's octet is just two.
Hydrogen doesn't want eight.
Hydrogen just wants two.
So we called it out
here, in the recipe.
Two for hydrogen. OK.
So add enough electrons
to form an octet.
Well see, each H
atom already has--
Remember they're sharing.
They're sharing.
OK?
So each H atom already has the
two electrons that it wants.
And so, for four I've got that--
oh, I started with the terminal.
Atoms.
OK.
And so for four, I've
got each H is OK.
It has two.
All right?
It has two electrons, which is
what it wants in its valence.
Next one.
If-- oh!
Now, it gets-- If there's
electrons left over
put them on the central atom.
OK.
So I went from the terminal in.
I went from the outside in.
H has two.
That's good.
Oh!
But how do I know if
I have any left over?
Well, I did that in step two.
I had a total
number of electrons.
Now, how many have I used?
I've used two here,
and I've used two here.
I have four left over,
because I started with eight.
Right?
And I was just
told from step five
to put those on
the central atom.
OK.
So step five now, is going to
make this look interesting.
So H, O, H--
and now, I'm not going
to put them in a bond.
Right?
I'm just going to
put them on the atom.
And those are
called non-bonding.
Well, OK.
That's a genius name.
Nonbinding.
Because they're not bonding.
[LAUGHS]
That's a good name
for those electrons.
You can also call those lone
pairs, because they're lone.
They're not involved in a bond.
All right?
So those are my four
extra electrons.
And then finally, if the central
atom is less than an octet,
used the lone pairs
from terminal atoms--
Oh, this looks complicated.
I don't want to deal with it.
Why?
Because I've got an
octet here already.
So six is not needed.
Because everything
since the oxygen--
since O is happy.
It's got its octet.
So that is a very slow--
we went slow.
We'll go faster now.
Right?
So that is a very
slow introduction
to how to do a Lewis dot
diagram for a molecule.
In this case, H2O.
Now, you may notice
I drew it linear.
Some of us know that is not
the shape of this molecule.
But shapes come later.
Shapes come next week, right?
Right now we're not
thinking about shapes.
Let's do another example.
So my next example is O, Cl.
I'm taking this and I'm
putting a charge on it.
So here's my next example.
Well, anyway, that's my example.
I'm going to go through
the numbers again.
We're going to go
a little faster.
So I want to know how
this looks in a Lewis.
Structure well, OK.
So there's only two atoms, so--
Maybe I should have called
this example B, because now I
have point 1, all right?
So there's only two atoms.
So there's no central atom.
OK, that sounds like
that might be easy.
And then step two is, how many
valence electrons are there?
Well, there's six, plus
seven, plus one, right?
So oxygen is six.
Chlorine is seven, plus
one, equals 14 electrons.
Where did the one come from?
That's because it's got
a negative charge here.
It's a negatively
charged molecule.
OK.
Good.
Now-- OK, now it
gets interesting.
Place bonding pair of electrons
between adjacent atoms.
So my adjacent atoms
are these two atoms,
which I could write like
this, or I could also
have written it like this.
OK?
Those are equivalent.
Now step four.
OK.
Now, starting with
the terminal atoms,
add enough electrons to
each one to form an octet.
So let's go through this.
So now step four.
OK.
Now, this can count
the two electrons.
This can count
those two electrons.
You see how this works?
Because we're sharing now.
No one took.
We're sharing.
So they can each
count those, because
of what I drew up there in terms
of how a convenient bond works.
But now, they need another
six to form an octet.
So how many?
I used two.
How many do I have left?
I've got 12 left.
It's perfect.
Right?
So I've got exactly
as many as I want.
And I can write O
has all of those.
Cl has all of these.
And if we want to
be careful about it,
we will emphasize that this
molecule is not neutral.
It got an extra electron.
That's why we put the
minus sign up there.
Right?
It's charged.
And this molecule, OK.
Each atom-- let's see, OK.
I used the extra electrons.
If electrons are left over--
No electrons left over.
If central atoms-- no,
they're already octets.
So five and six are not needed.
Oh, but you know
the last example
is going to be more interesting.
So let's do that.
Last example.
O-- C, example C. O--
so I've got H, OK.
I'm just going to
write the atoms here,
because I'm starting
where I don't even know
what it's going to look like.
I don't even want to hint at it.
Those are my atoms.
I've got two hydrogens,
an oxygen, and a chlorine.
OK.
I'm sorry, a carbon.
Oh, yeah.
I meant this to be a carbon.
There we go.
Two hydrogens, an
oxygen, and carbon.
OK.
Now, as we will see when I tell
you what electronegativity is,
carbon has the lowest
electronegativity.
OK?
And so, I'm going to
put that in the center.
That's going to tell me
that if I answer point 1,
it might look
something like this.
Oh, now it's taking
some form, right?
OK?
So the hydrogens are
going to go like that.
Their terminally oxygen is
outside, carbons in the middle.
And how many
electrons do I have?
OK, so now, let's see.
Answering step two, I've
got 12 valence electrons.
OK.
Because I've got six,
four, five, right?
So 12.
OK?
Good.
And now, I'm going to put
the bonding pair in there.
So let's do that.
So step three--
OK, so now I've got C, H, H,
O. So I've done step three.
OK.
So I've got two, four, six.
I've used up six electrons
in this sharing covalent bond
situation, and I
started with 12.
So that means I've got six left.
OK.
So I'm going to go to step four.
Now, starting with the terminal
atoms, add enough to each one
to form an octet.
Now hydrogen is good, right?
Because hydrogen, remember,
it's octet is a doublet.
It's two.
So that's good.
But what about oxygen?
OK.
It looks like oxygen needs some.
So now, we're going to write
this structure like this.
I've got to add six more
electrons to oxygen in order
to fulfill its octet, right?
And oxygen is happy.
All right?
Yeah, it is.
Just like that.
But if electrons are
left over-- but are
there any electrons left over?
No.
So I can't place electrons
on the center atom,
yet now we invoke number six.
If central less than an octet--
it is two, two, two--
then use lone pairs
from terminal atoms
to form multiple bonds
to the central atom.
Oh, yeah.
Now we're there.
So now we jump to step six.
Because look.
Let's continue.
Because look, if I add all
these up and I go to carbon,
it's not happy.
But let's make it happy, because
that's what Lewis lets us do.
And I'm going to
go down to here--
six continued.
And all I need to
do to do that is
to follow the instructions,
which is, taking one lone pair
and put it here.
So I'm going to draw these
explicitly now as dots, right?
So I took one of those lone
pairs and I moved it here.
And I created a
stronger sharing bond.
I wrote down the guidelines
of Lewis, remember, on Monday.
And the third point was octet!
Right?
Atoms want to achieve
their nearest octet.
And this this tells
us then, by following
these steps to implement
Lewis' dream and vision,
we get nothing less than
the nature of bonding itself
in molecules.
That's cool.
And so you could write this
with sticks if you want.
C, H-- that's a double bond
with those electrons up there.
It's the same thing.
And now, if you count--
happy, happy, happy, happy.
Everybody's happy.
Caring is sharing.
They're all sharing.
So this is the
general idea of Lewis.
Following the Lewis prescription
tells us about covalent bonds,
and it tells us
how many electrons
are going to be shared.
Now, it also tells us something
else that's very important,
and it's through this
concept called formal charge.
So that's the next thing
that we need to learn.
Because now, I go
to another molecule.
In this case, it's formaldehyde.
OK.
CH2O.
But look, now, neither
of these is done.
These are not done.
But it's like my starting place.
OK.
Carbon central here.
It's kind of central-ish there.
Can I start with
either of these?
And the answer is yes, you can.
And you can draw--
and let's do that--
you can actually
draw correct Lewis structures.
Let me use the board over here.
All right?
So I could draw this like this.
H-- Let me see here.
H, C, double bond, O, hydrogen.
And I could put that there
and that there.
Or I could draw it like this.
Do I have it this way?
Yes.
All right?
Like this.
And carbon double bond O.
And when I look at this, and
I look at the electron count,
it all works out.
All right?
I got to add my lone
pairs to the oxygen.
Don't let me forget those.
It all works out.
The total number of valence
electrons is 12 in both cases,
and everybody's
obeying the octet rule.
But the concept of
formal charge allows
us to distinguish
between which one
is likely to be more stable.
And so, what formal charge is--
and I've got it written out
here--
OK?
So formal charge--
non-binding electrons
count for the given atom.
Bonding electrons
are divided equally.
And so formal charge is the
total valence of an atom--
so I can take atom here and
say, what's it's total valence?
Carbon, four.
Oxygen, six.
All right?
So that's the total
balance of the free atom.
And then I subtract
from that how many
nonbinding electrons it has,
plus the bonding ones over two.
Right?
And so, if I do that--
let's write that.
So if I think about that--
gesundheit-- from my
pictures, the formal charge
is equal to the number
of valence electrons
of the free atom.
That means the
atom, before it ever
participated in a bond,
minus the number of dots,
minus the number of lines.
Because that is really the
same definition, right?
That's the same definition.
So let's go up to this one.
So now, if I look at carbon
in this configuration,
and I calculate the
formal charge of carbon,
it's going to be 4--
the valence electron
of the free atom--
minus 2-- because it's got
the two dots there, right?
Minus 3-- 1, 2, 3.
Or the total number of
electrons involved in bonds
divided by two--
6 over 2.
3, right?
So those are equivalent.
But that means that the
formal charge on this is--
just spell it out here for now--
formal charge is equal to -1.
And if I do the same
thing here, then it's +1.
But you see, if I look
at this structure,
and I think about the formal
charge on the carbon, atom--
Again, I'm basically counting
a change from the free atom.
OK?
And so carbon had four.
What did this new
bonding environment
do to the valence chemistry?
And in this case, the
formal charge on carbon
is going to be 4--
starting with the number
of free valence electrons--
minus no dots, but it's got
one, two, three, four bonds.
So that's zero.
And the formal
charge on the oxygen
is going to be 6 minus
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
So that's also zero.
And you get a
sense-- how much did
I push this atom away from
where it normally thinks
about its charge balance?
And you get a sense for
why this might be true.
Lewis structure with a set of
formal charges closest to 0
is usually the most stable.
And that's our guideline.
And so, this one not very happy.
That one happy.
And so you can calculate the
formal charge on any atom
in any Lewis
structure-- gesundheit--
by following this
very simple procedure.
You take any atom and you look
at how you've drawn it's Lewis
structure, right?
And you just count.
So for example, if I
take CO2, and I think,
well, I can do the
same thing here.
I've got two Lewis
structures and they look like
they both satisfy the recipe.
The recipe is satisfied.
But which one is more stable?
Well, if I look at this,
it's the same idea.
And I won't go
through it in detail,
but if I look at this then--
C, O, O, with lone pairs
on the Os, like that.
All right?
This is going to give me
formal charges of 0, 0, and 0.
Whereas, if I do the one on the
right and I put a triple bond--
so I put too many
electrons sharing--
then yeah, I
satisfied the octets,
but no, I'm not as stable,
because the formal charges
aren't as close to zero.
So this gives me to my brief,
why this matters for take.
Why would I care which
one of these CO2 takes?
All right?
OK.
Well, it turns out that as long
as we're not at absolute zero,
this molecule is moving.
And so, obviously,
that's related to this.
It's not obvious.
But cars in the US are now
the number one emitter of CO2.
OK?
They're the number one
cause of CO2 emissions.
And here's a nice
little corner somewhere.
And so, this is coming out now
from the transportation sector.
More of the CO2 comes from
that than any other sector.
Why does it matter?
Well, why does this
Lewis structure matter?
Well, it has to do
with how it moves.
Because, you see, I
showed you this before.
And I didn't complete it because
we were talking about electron
transitions, and then
I gave you the example
of ozone being really important
for absorbing in the UV.
And I showed you the chemistry
of ozone degradation with CFCs.
You see, look at this
absorption out here.
There's CO2, right?
And so, there's the sunlight
above the atmosphere.
Here it is on Earth.
And you could see CO2 there.
But see, the reason
CO2 absorbs there
has to do with how it moves.
It has to do with
its vibrations.
Now, that's not
something that you
need to know for like
a test or something,
but I wanted to tell you about
it because it is directly
related to what we just did.
Those vibrations--
and by the way,
that first mode is the one
out here doing all the IR
absorption.
Right?
This one.
And you can see right away,
if this thing is wiggling,
it's going to wiggle
very differently.
Right?
It's going to wiggle very
differently whether it
has two double bonds on
either side of the carbon,
or a triple and a single.
Right?
And so that, alone,
tells you something
really important
about how it interacts
in our atmosphere with
radiant heat, right?
With IR radiation.
OK.
That's my 'why this matters.'
Now, I've been talking about
all these things in absolutes.
But you see, the world
is not so absolute.
And in fact, we're missing
a really important part
of the picture here.
So this is H2, right?
There is an iconic bond where,
remember, it's like, I'm picky!
OK.
And then it's like a
Coulomb interaction.
And here it's a sharing.
Each electron sees
both of those protons.
But there's a whole bunch
of room in between, right?
There's a whole bunch
of room in between.
And so what we need next, as
we talk about covalent bonds,
is we need a way to think
about how ionic they are.
Right?
Because there's only a
certain kind of covalent bond
that's purely covalent.
As it's written here--
non-polar covalent.
So let's talk about that next.
And what we're going
to do is use this term
that I alluded to in
the beginning, which
is point number
one in your recipe,
and that is electronegativity.
OK?
So I'm going to get it done.
Almost.
Practice makes perfect.
OK.
All right.
So there is a
symbol kai, that we
use for this concept
of electronegativity.
Electronegativity.
OK?
Now, this is the
tendency of an atom
to attract shared pair
of electrons to itself.
OK?
Let's write "in a
bond," just to be sure.
All right?
In a bond.
So if an electron in a
bond, the question is,
how much was it able to pull
those bonding electrons to it?
All right?
And you can already think
about this in terms of concepts
that we've learned already.
Right?
Like the size of an atom.
How far out electrons are?
Right?
The radius of an atom.
Whether there's
shielding going on.
Right?
This kind of leads you--
how many protons there are.
All right?
This leads you already to
be able to think about this.
Which atom is going to want a
pair of electrons in a bond,
right?
Which one is going to want
it more, and how much?
But it was Pauling who said,
no, I want to go further that.
I want to write down--
even if it's empirical--
I want to write down
some way, some number.
I want to quantify this.
And so he came up with a
scale for electronegativity.
The term and concept
of electronegativity
goes back long before Pauling,
to, I think, [INAUDIBLE]..
But Pauling is the one who
said, I want to quantify this.
And the way we're
going to do is we're
going to measure bonding
energies between all sorts
of different atoms.
And what he found is
that, if a bonds to a,
and b bonds to b, a to b is not
just a simple sum of the two.
And that clued him
in for how to think
about this partially covalent
or polar covalent nature.
I'll tell you why that
word "polar" is there
in a few minutes.
And so Pauling
developed this scale--
the electronegativity
scale-- to tell us this.
And he arbitrarily set
fluorine to four and hydrogen
at first 2.1, now it's 2.2.
But basically, this is
just some of the elements
of the periodic table, and these
are their electronegativities.
OK?
And you don't need to worry
about how this scale was
developed quantitatively.
There are actually many
electronegativity scales.
OK?
What I want you to know is
what it means conceptually,
and then how to use
it to think about
whether a bond is going
to be ionic, or covalent,
or somewhere in between.
And so, you can see already
here, OK, the extremes of this
are fluorine and caesium.
These are the most
electronegative,
least electronegative, or if you
want to be positive about it,
most electropositive.
When you're talking
to these elements
you want them to feel good.
They're not the least.
They're very important.
So they're electropositive.
Right?
And now you know conceptually.
But look, now we also can
think about differences.
Because, if the difference
between this concept,
from one atom to
another is zero,
well then, that must be
a pure covalent bond.
Because neither one could
bring in the electron pair
more than the other, right?
So like chlorine two--
the chlorine dimer-- then the
change in electronegativity
between one chlorine and another
is zero, it's a pure covalent.
I mean, just think about
that conceptually, right?
So that's what
electronegativity means.
So if I have two that are the
same, neither one can draw in.
They have the same kai.
Neither one can draw the
pair towards them more.
Right?
So the same is true for
any dimer like this,
where it's the same atom.
The H2 dimer that we started
with, also has delta kai of 0.
Those are called pure covalent,
because it's just pure sharing.
Nobody took more
charge than the other.
But see, if I go to something
like sodium chloride,
well now, from this
table I can calculate
the difference in
electronegativity
between sodium and chlorine.
And it's 2.23, which
is pretty high.
And it's ionic.
So if that difference is high,
then it means one of the atoms
grabbed the electrons.
And if it's kind of
0, it's pure covalent.
And if it's
somewhere in between,
it's this polar covalent.
So, for example, HCL.
So these are all with
the same atom-- chlorine.
But here delta kai
is equal to 0.96.
So this is called
polar covalent.
OK?
So this is also
partially ionic, right?
These mean the same things.
There's ionic character-- is
another way that we say it.
This bond is not purely
covalent because one of them
took a little more charge,
because it's electronegativity
was higher.
And therefore,
there's a little bit
of that kind of
ionic thing going on,
because you got a little plus
over here, and a little minus
over there.
Right?
And that is
something that can be
looked at for a whole
bunch of different bonds.
And so here, this is what
Pauling was trying to fit.
So he came up with
these empirical fits.
Right?
OK, things kind of tend
to lie on this line, which
is the plot of the
electronegativity difference
between two different atoms
the percent ionic character.
Is it really fully ionic?
Is it is it fully covalent?
And you can see, over here, it's
kind of not interesting, right?
It's just anything
with itself is zero.
And over here, you've got
some of the same ionic bonds
that we've already
talked about, right?
And then you've got all
this stuff in between.
And what this says is, as
you've now seen, right?
[INAUDIBLE] is a
suggestion of a rule,
and then it gets
broken 20% of the time.
This is also a way of
qualitatively classifying
bonds and thinking about the
ionic character in a bond,
but it is not
always quantitative.
But in general,
what you'll see is
that if delta kai is
greater than 2, then
it tends to be an ionic bond.
And if delta kai is less
than, let's say, 1.6,
it tends to be covalent
or polar covalent.
And in-between it depends.
How do I know?
Right?
I'll show you an example.
Where's my example?
I've got an example here.
Sodium bromide.
It's not on there.
But if I take sodium
bromide and I take HF,
they both have
delta kai equal 1.9.
Now, some textbooks
will simply say 1.7.
You will see that
in some textbooks,
because they just want
it to be all or nothing.
It's always ionic, or it's--
But the fact of
the matter is that
in this intermediate
regime you get variations
that depend on other things.
And so, for example, HF is
a gas at room temperature.
So these have the same
electronegativity difference,
but this really behaves like
a polar covalent molecule.
And this really behaves
like an ionic solid--
an ionic bond.
How do you know?
It's the properties.
Right?
Remember, I showed
you the properties
of ionic solids on Monday.
And so, I can look at
those and check them off--
solid at room
temperature, et cetera.
And I can see, well,
does this fit the bill?
Does it look like
an iconic solid?
It absolutely does not.
So even though this
is the same, you
got to be careful in
this intermediate regime.
Now, you can also
go even further,
and you can get quantitative.
Because, you see, what we're
really talking about here
is something called a dipole.
That is why it's
called polar covalent.
OK?
It's called polar covalent
because we made a dipole.
And as far as I know, from
my electricity and magnetism
training, the dipole moment--
mu, it's written as mu--
is the charge
times the distance.
Where Q is that the charge.
In this case, it's literally
the charge that was pulled.
It's exactly that.
There's the chart, right?
Tendency to pull
a shared electron.
I pulled it over
here, so I created
a little more
negative charge on me,
and a little positive
charge on there.
And that meant that I've
got a partial charge now,
separated by a distance.
Right?
And so you can actually use
this to get quantitative.
So let's do sodium
chloride, right?
So for sodium chloride the
dipole moment is nine to debye.
And this is just one debye.
This is charge times distance,
so one debye is equal to 3.3.
10 to the minus
30th coulomb meters.
That's the units of a dipole
moment-- charge times distance.
So if I take sodium
chloride and I tell you
that its dipole
moment is nine debye,
then I also have to tell you
that the distance between them,
r, is equal to 2.36 angstroms.
That is this distance here.
I've made a bond between
these two things,
and that bond is
some distance apart.
Well, that's
exactly the distance
I need to think about
the dipole, right?
So remember, a dipole
is because I've
got positive charge
and negative charge.
And in fact, you might
see it written like this.
You might see there's a
little positive charge here,
and a little negative
charge there,
and the dipole moment
goes like that.
All right?
There's a dipole.
And now, those charges at
this distance in the bond
allow me to actually
be quantitative,
because Q is equal to mu over r.
And if I plug that in,
then it's 1.3 times 10
to the minus 19th coulombs.
So for sodium chloride--
because I was given the dipole
moment in that molecule,
and I can look up
the bonds distance--
I can actually tell you how
much charge are on those atoms
if I know that information.
But I also know what the
charge of a full electron is.
This is almost there.
It's something like
80% of an electron.
And so that's a pretty
strong ionic bond.
But it's not 100%, right?
So this is the message
I want to tell you.
In reality, we've been
talking about absolutes.
I fully took a charge.
Right?
No!
You didn't.
You took 80%.
And there's a little
bit still over there.
Right?
But we do like to still
categorize materials.
And that's what this
does really nicely,
is it says, well, this is going
to behave like an iconic solid.
Meaning, it's going to
have those properties
that I showed you on Monday.
Right?
Even though it's not fully
ionic, it's pretty darn ionic.
Right?
And now, even though these
are not fully covalent,
meaning, pure, non-polar
covalent-- non-polar,
no dipole in the bond.
But these have some
dipole, but that's OK.
They're still acting
like covalent molecules.
Right?
And so there's this
spectrum in between.
And you can use these concepts
to think about the bonding,
and to think about in particular
this-- that so many bonds are
actually like this.
Even though we categorize
them like this,
and we think about
them like that,
they actually look like this.
And electronegativity
and dipoles
are what help us characterize
these differences.
Now, there is more to Lewis that
I will talk about on Friday.
But there's something
called resonant structures,
and that's a very
important part of Lewis.
I'm going to talk
about it Friday,
and it will not be on
the exam on Monday.
OK?
But on Friday, we'll talk
about resonance structures,
we'll do a few more
Lewis examples,
and then I'll talk
about exam one.